autonomous driving is a big
technological challenge
probably the biggest of our generation
this is a tesla it comes with a feature
known as
autopilot and elon musk says in the
future it'll have a feature called
full self driving several other cars
being sold today also come with assisted
driving technology
which still requires someone behind the
wheel but new vehicles that won't have
anyone in the driver's seat are getting
closer to production
startups waymo cruise too simple and
aurora
are already testing driverless tech on
some public roads across
america it's going to move quickly we'll
start to see this
move from prototypes to actually scaling
products into the world
we see us becoming fully driverless in
2024
as they invest billions in r d and sign
multi-billion dollar deals
their valuations have soared and too
simple has gone public
they're pitching a future where people
won't even own cars younger generations
won't even think about
owning cars and some jobs will no longer
exist we fundamentally believe that
every trucker
will be able to retire as a trucker but
first of all they need to convince
governments and the public that their
technology is safe you're limiting your
potential if consumers are not
comfortable getting into your vehicle
and taking a ride
so could these startups make driving a
thing of the past
tesla has been working on making its
vehicles autonomous since around 2016
and said it planned to have self-driving
cars on the road by 2020.
and sometimes i'm not on time but
i get it done for now experts say these
cars have what they call level 2
autonomy
it is a level 2 system where they're
saying that the driver has to be there
they have to pay attention they're
counting on them
what does that mean well it's a scale
used by auto engineers and it starts at
zero which means
you know kind of a 1950s car with no
automation at all
and goes up to level five basically when
the car
can do everything anywhere you can drop
it off
in afghanistan today
and it will be able to operate without
maps by itself
instead of releasing vehicles and
working towards autonomy
these top startups want to roll them out
directly at level 4
autonomy which is where the car doesn't
need a driver as long as it's pre-loaded
with information about its surroundings
like maps and directions and we just
simply think
level 4 is the goal for any
domain some companies in the us and asia
like baidu
auto x and dd say they've reached level
4 in some vehicles though none have
rolled them out at commercial scale
but some are getting close waymo and
cruz have piloted a fleet of robo taxis
in some ring-fenced areas around the us
think ride-hailing without the driver
like this the waymo won
we're the only company that has a fully
autonomous ride-hailing service
available to the public today in the
phoenix metro area
in late 2020 waymo began removing
support drivers from its vehicles after
its cars racked up some 20 million miles
on public roads
gathering troves of data for its
algorithms the car shows up completely
empty
they take a ride from point a to point b
that's one of the ways you make this
real
is you launch a service in the city and
you see if customers will actually adopt
a service and use it
waymo started as a google project in
2009
and now has a 30 billion valuation an
alphabet google's parent
as a majority shareholder cruz has
roughly the same valuation as waymo and
is owned by gm
with whom it has built an autonomous
vehicle from scratch it has accrued
fewer miles in waymo some 2 million
in its tests in san francisco miles
driven absolutely
matters because ultimately the goal is
to put
this technology on public roads
interacting with other human driven
vehicles so you do need
that experience at some point to say
yes this is not only safe but it's
actually viable
crews recently got permission to remove
the support driver but it's yet to carry
paying passengers it plans to begin
production of this vehicle the origin in
2023
we spoke with company representatives
over the phone who said gm's backing
is a strategic advantage but it's not
just cars
startups are also eyeing trucks the
trucking industry
is a massive industry it's four trillion
dollars globally
800 billion dollars in the us alone
that's the market aurora and two simple
are betting on
aurora which has received investment
from uber says it has a handful of test
vehicles out
on public roads in the u.s too simple
has around 60 autonomous trucks
circulating on highways in the southwest
with support drivers
it was the first driverless company in
the u.s to go public
getting a roughly 8.5 billion valuation
in the us alone 60
000 driver shortage this year that would
increase to about 160 000 by 2028 based
on
latest numbers so it's a very real
problem we don't intend to ever build a
car or build a truck
uh we work with great companies like
pacar and volvo and toyota
uh and integrate our technology into
their vehicles i think consumer goods
uh can provide you know an easier path
you're already kind of simplifying the
situations that you would have to deal
with you're driving the same pathway
often you're not going to have
pedestrians and cyclists
you know interacting with traffic but
their tech needs to overcome some big
challenges before it can be widely
adopted
and the more we discover about the
challenges the more we learn about how
long this is going to take and so i
think you saw all of industry start to
reset
expectations waymo and others had
previously said 2020 was a year that
robo taxis would become commonplace
across the us
but the coronavirus pandemic and
technical hurdles have led to forecasts
being pushed back
one issue these vehicles still don't
work well at night or in bad weather
it's not a coincidence that you see
companies testing in fair weather places
first
when you think about the barriers it's
really engineering barriers
it's time it takes capital but
we'll get there but those are not the
only barriers
honda civic right there colliding with
the waymo van we're being told
it was not at fault in this accident the
industry has to address safety concerns
as autonomous cars have been involved in
a number of accidents in recent years
after a fatal crash in 2018 where a
car's built-in
automatic emergency braking system was
disabled uber had to stop testing
autonomous vehicles in arizona
it continued tests in other cities
before selling its unprofitable
self-driving car unit to aurora at the
end of 2020.
all players in this industry know that
they have to deal with a lot of
skepticism there's this suggestion that
the technology is presenting new risk or
first risk
the reality is though roads have risk so
it's not possible to make anything 100
safe whether it's a toothbrush or an
airliner
and so we we try to make these systems
really safe a recent study found that
even if autonomous vehicles caused
accidents at half the rate of human
drivers only 37 percent of americans
would opt in
we've got more forgiveness we've got
more understanding if that happens
or is caused by another human driver i
don't think we have that same compassion
for a robot that might produce the same
result
to show that self-driving vehicles cause
very few accidents
waymo started disclosing all of its
crashes and near misses in arizona
a total of 47 episodes over 2019 and
2020
because we thought it was really
important to start to demonstrate
that you insert a fully autonomous
vehicle into an ecosystem
and there's still human error around the
vehicle sure we've got disengagements
we've got miles driven
we've got the number of crashes and we
can relate that to human drivers
but that doesn't necessarily make it
much easier to kind of say this
is safe safer or safe enough
so so just being able to quantify these
things i think is going to be
is still a challenge for the industry